un nuevo golpe a las mujeres afganas el
gobierno talibán les prohibió trabajar
en cualquier organización no
gubernamental presente en el país el
mandato se justificó al considerar que
sus empleadas no están cumpliendo con
las leyes islámicas talibanes están
ordenando a las mujeres que no trabajen
ahora tengo una familia que cuidar cómo
podremos sobrevivir mi marido está
enfermo no puede trabajar tengo que
pagar las facturas el alquiler de la
casa comprar medicinas y si no trabajo
por todas las cosas que tengo que pagar
de Dónde puedo sacar el dinero Qué vamos
a hacer la ong como el consejo noruego
para los refugiados argullaron que con
esta imposición no pueden llegar de
manera efectiva los afganos que
necesitan de su labor sin las mujeres
factor fundamental en su fuerza laboral
esto llega en el peor momento posible
cuando la economía de Afganistán se está
derrumbando y necesitamos mujeres como
parte de la fuerza laboral para permitir
que la economía se recupere
el secretario de estado estadounidense
Anthony blink también condenó la
decisión profundamente preocupado porque
la prohibición de los talibanes de que
las mujeres entreguen ayuda humanitaria
en Afganistán interrumpirá la asistencia
vital para millones de personas desde el
regreso de los talibanes al poder los
derechos de las mujeres han sufrido un
retroceso significativo la obligación de
transitar a compañeros por un hombre en
largos trayectos y más reciente la
revocación del acceso a la educación
superior son algunas de las imposiciones